JeJean-Michel Leprince.
- - Novembre 2021, la Cour supre
dede Colombie examine une requêe
d'd'une ONG d'activistes, la Cae
jujuste, qui revendique le droit
àà l'avortement. La Colombie est
unun pays plutôt conservateur et
trtrès catholique et l'oppositin
àà ce droit s'exprime fortement
popour des motifs religieux.
LeLe foulard vert est devenu
papartout le signe de ralliement
dedes partisans du libre choix.
CeCe sont les verts qui gagnent.
EnEn février dernier,
lala Cour suprême dépénalise
l'l'avortement jusqu'à 24 semais
dede grossesse. Causa Justa aurt
prpréféré la dépénalisation tote
mamais le progrès est là.
" "La Colombie est aujourd'huin
papays plus juste pour les femm,
avavec moins de discrimination
etet qui nous reconnaît comme
êêtres humains libres et égaux."
RéRéaction prévisible de
l'l'archevêque de Bogota :
" "Nous devons respecter la vie
ddès la gestation et jusqu'à
lala mort naturelle."
LeLe président, Ivan Duque, lui,
ututilise le mot : atroce.
" "Atroce de permettre
l'l'interruption d'une vie
jujusqu'à six mois de gestation"
L Les Colombiennes reviennent
dede loin.
" "La femme qui avortait risqut
jujusqu'à six ans de prison, dit
lele médecin chef de Profamilia,
jujusqu'en 2006."
AvAvant, les a avortements
ététaient clandestins et
lele docteur Vargas a vu bien
dedes cas de complications sévès
etet de morts de très jeunes
fefemmes.
D Donc à partir de 2006,
dadans le réseau privé
dede cliniques Profamilia,
ququi depuis 1965 se consacre
àà la planification familiale,
ilil se pratique des avortement.
MaMais a trois conditions pour
ququ'il soit légal : en cas
dede violence sexuelle, de dangr
popour le foetus ou pour la sané
dede la mère.
SaSanté physique ou mentale,
nonotion bien large, qui
pepermettait un avortement
susur avis d'un médecin,
rerelativement facile à obtenir.
1616 ans plus tard, il suffit
dede se présenter à la clinique.
I Il faut cliquer sur
lala case qui dit : interruption
vovolontaire de grossesse et
lele nom de la patiente devient
unun code anonyme. Elle consulte
unun médecin qui lui prescrit
unune interruption chimique
ouou physique selon l'avancement
dede la grossesse. L'interventin
a a lieu le lendemain.
C C'est une procédure souple
etet surtout basée sur le droità
l'l'information et le libre cho.
DeDes psychologues sont à
lala disposition des patients.
LeLe Canada finance le programme
VaValiente de Profamilia qui
aiaide les jeunes à assumer leus
drdroits sexuels et reproducteu.
L L'accès légal à l'avortement
a a fait des progrès
spspectaculaires un peu partout
enen Amérique latine ces derniès
anannées. Il est légal depuis
lolongtemps à Cuba, en Uruguay,
dadans certaines parties
dudu Mexique, en Argentine,
plplus récent : en Bolivie,
auau Chili, sous certaines
coconditions. Il reste difficile
auau Brésil et au Pérou.
UnUne région demeure
paparticulièrement répressive :
c'c'est l'Amérique centrale.
J Jean-Michel Leprince,
R Radio-Canada, Bogot